huge number of people in the media
decided now was the time to link musk
and the alt-right and the so-called
Jewish question and support the notion
that musk is some sort of Crypton Nazi
so something really interesting happened
over the last couple days uh there was a
tweet from an account this is just a
completely as far as I know a totally
random Twitter account but it ended up
getting Elon Musk into a bunch of hot
water so I want to show you this uh this
guy this guy it's it's just breaking bat
whatever that is wrote Jewish
communities have been pushing the exact
kind of dialectical hatred against
whites that they claim to want people to
stop using against them I'm deeply
disinterested in giving the tiniest now
about Western Jewish populations coming
to the disturbing realization that those
hordes of minorities that support
flooding their country don't exactly
like them too much you want the truth
said to your face there it is now I will
unpack that tweet in just a moment what
what the reason that that Twitter uh
that that tweet specifically went viral
is because Elon Musk responded to that
and said you have said the actual truth
okay so you might hear that original
statement Jewish communities and feel
like there's something anti-semetic
going on here now it gets cleaned up
just a bit because now suddenly
everybody started calling Elon Musk an
anti-semite so then Elon Musk followed
up and he said the ADL unjustly attacks
the majority of the West despite the
majority of the West supporting the
Jewish people and Israel this is because
they cannot by their own tenants
criticize the minority groups who are
their primary threat it is not right and
it needs to stop so that is 100% right
that is absolutely clear uh a random
person on Twitter cleaned it up a bit
more for Elon he wrote yes but it is not
fair to say or truthful to say that
Jewish communities promote dialectical
hatred towards whites say what you want
about the ADL but don't generalize about
the Jewish community and Elon responded
to that you're right that this does not
extend to all Jewish communities but it
also not just limited to the ad L okay
so you get the point here what someone
what this original person was saying is
there are these groups like The ADL now
he said Jewish community so that's a
little bit butchered and I'm going to
get to a video of Ben Shapiro cleaning
this up a bit more in just a second but
the overriding point that there are
groups like The ADL who spend way too
much time calling everyone on the right
Hitler racist and bigoted and Trump's
evil and all of those things rather than
deal with the people who are here now
who are chanting for genocide and
everything else and and in many cases
who have led to a lot of the bad
immigration policies and tried to take
out anyone who has wanted a border or
anything else that was elon's point he
followed up one more time on this he
said and at the risk of being repetitive
I am deeply offended by the adl's
messaging and any other groups who push
de facto anti-white racism or anti-asian
racism or racism of any kind I'm sick of
it stop now okay these are all by the
way themes that I talk about on this
show all the time right so obviously
I've been a big defender of the Jewish
people and of Israel but I am constantly
defending white people and Christian
people and straight people and Asian
people because these things are all
deeply connected to how evil
collectivism and wokeness is so over the
last two days there has been a massive
assault by Media Matters and the ADL and
a bunch of these other companies to
boycott Twitter right hit Elon Musk
where it hurts go after his advertisers
well Ben Shapiro got word of this and he
fully defended Elon Musk and it's
certainly true there are a lot of
liberal Jewish organizations that
supported a lot of the same policies
that have now imported a lot of people
who really hate Jews and westerners into
the west and a lot of the very same
people who are pushing Dei
intersectional politics are now
realizing the wages of
that that's true a huge number of people
in the media decided now was the time to
link musk in the alt-right and the
so-called Jewish question and support
the notion that musk is some sort of
crypto naazi now it's not a coincidence
again that a lot of the people doing
just that are happily calling for Israel
to ceasefire in its war with Kamas see
very often anti-Semitism becomes a
political football when you can hang the
label on Donald Trump or Elon Musk and
you're on the left you do it however
when you're forced to denounce proas
protesters shouting from The River To
The Sea Palestine must be free suddenly
you get a little shy thus the same media
leaping on both Trump and musk has been
downplaying the open Jew hatred at
massive Pro protests around the globe
instead propagating Lawes about Israel's
supposed human rights violations instead
they're focusing in on their political
enemies like Trump and musk and teeming
them the acolytes of Hitler meanwhile
the actual Hitler acolytes were out
there waving mind comp they're like
those people I mean they are a Preston
Brown all right so you get it if you lay
it out cleaner than Ben there is no
reason to think that Elon Musk is an
anti-semite even if you want to get hung
up on Jewish communities right as
opposed to Jew you know these Lefty
Jewish related organizations like
everyone sees exactly what's going on
here